I had it in my mind that I wanted to propose to Sean during the trip. You know, we've been together like three and a half years, and we're going to Vegas. What more romantic place is there? Last June, my friend Courtney decided to propose marriage in the world capital of spontaneous marriage proposals. And I was like, yeah, but I don't know how I'm going to do it. I have, you know, I have the thing with me, but I don't know how I'm gonna do it. I have, you know, I have the thing with me, but I don't know when or where.
我当时心里想的是，我想在旅行期间向肖恩求婚。你知道，我们在一起大概三年半了，而且我们要去拉斯维加斯。还有什么地方比那里更浪漫呢？去年六月，我的朋友考特尼决定在世界“即兴求婚之都”求婚。我当时想，是啊，但我不知道该怎么做。你知道，东西我带在身上了，但我不知道该怎么做。你知道，东西我带在身上了，但我不知道该在什么时候、什么地点做。
Courtney waited and waited for the right moment until it was the last night of their trip when they were hanging out in Caesar's Palace. We're sitting at the bar and we got a couple drinks and we were kind of just killing time before a flight. I reached into my bag and I pulled out this small leather box that I'd been holding onto all weekend. And I'm like, will you marry me? Like, I think those are the words that I said. It all was kind of a blur. But inside of the box wasn't a ring. It was a Pokemon game
考特尼一直在等待合适的时机，直到旅行的最后一晚，他们待在凯撒宫的时候。我们坐在酒吧里，喝了几杯酒，在赶飞机前消磨时间。我伸手进包里，掏出了那个我整个周末都随身携带的小皮盒。我说，你愿意嫁给我吗？我想我当时说的是这些话。一切都有点模糊。但盒子里装的不是戒指，而是一个宝可梦游戏
cartridge. Courtney and Sean love Pokemon, and they've been wanting to play two versions of it called Ruby and Sapphire. Things that were very special to us, and they're both gemstones. Why not a ring? For a lot of reasons, I was just like, I don't think that a ring is that important. I think that something important to both of us,
卡带。考特尼和肖恩都喜欢宝可梦，他们一直想玩《红宝石》和《蓝宝石》这两个版本。这些对我们来说非常有意义，而且它们都是宝石。为什么不是戒指呢？出于很多原因，我当时就觉得，我不认为戒指那么重要。我认为对我们俩来说重要的东西，
that'll be really meaningful. But what I didn't realize about my like flawless plan to propose with something more meaningful than a ring, was that it's not understood on the surface as a proposal. At first, Sean wasn't sure if Courtney was serious. And I have to admit, when I saw a picture of Sean holding up a Pokemon cartridge with the caption, I said yes, I absolutely thought it was a joke. People were texting us like, are you actually getting married? Is this real or is this like a joke? And I was like, yeah, of course it's real.
那才更有意义。但我没意识到的是，我那个用比戒指更有意义的东西来求婚的“完美计划”，在表面上并不会被理解为求婚。起初，肖恩不确定考特尼是不是认真的。我必须承认，当我看到肖恩拿着宝可梦卡带的照片，配文写着“我答应了”时，我绝对以为这是个玩笑。人们发短信问我们：你们真的要结婚了吗？这是真的还是开玩笑？我说，当然是真的。
Real. As real as this 2018 Diamond commercial. I will spend my future with you, and I will be honest with you. And it will be wild. It will be kind, and it will be real. And as it fades to black, a tagline across the screen reads, real is rare. Real is a diamond. But reality and rarity are subjective.
真的。就像这则2018年的钻石广告一样真实。我将与你共度余生，我会对你坦诚。这会是狂野的。这会是温柔的，这会是真实的。当画面渐黑时，屏幕上出现了一句标语：真实即稀有。真实即钻石。但现实和稀有是主观的。
It matters of love, definitely, and certainly in the matter of diamonds. ["Diamonds"] Articles of interest, a show about what we wear. Season two. People don't realize it's fantasy. It's always this thing that you have to work extra hard to get. Mm. And that's so good. No one dresses like a king anymore.
这绝对关乎爱，当然也关乎钻石。《Articles of Interest》，一档关于我们穿戴之物的节目。第二季。人们没有意识到这是幻想。这总是一种你需要付出额外努力才能得到的东西。嗯。这太棒了。现在没人像国王那样穿衣服了。
How do you make money? That's how we make money, love. There are lots of things that we take for granted that would once have been considered luxuries. I'm walking down West 47th Street. I mean, come on. What kind of radio producer would I be if I didn't start a story about Diamond's exactly where you'd expect?
你们怎么赚钱？我们就是这样赚钱的，亲爱的。有很多我们认为理所当然的事情，曾经都被视为奢侈品。我正走在西47街上。拜托，如果我不从你预料之中的地方开始讲钻石的故事，那我算什么电台制作人呢？
Manhattan's Diamond District, baby. I am not the mess. Are you shopping or something? Oh, I'm just looking around. I'm just wondering how it's like very store to stores. Yeah. Not really that much of a difference. It's not everybody basically has the same freaking day. Julian is out here in front of his diamond shop, Just Hustlin. He's been working this storefront for 20 years. In the diamond district, it's all a crazy game
曼哈顿的钻石区，宝贝。我不是那个混乱。你在购物还是什么的？哦，我只是随便看看。我只是好奇这里店与店之间有什么不同。是的。其实没什么太大区别。不是每个人基本上都在过着同样该死的日子吗？朱利安正站在他的钻石店前，忙碌着。他在这个店面工作了20年。在钻石区，这完全是一场疯狂的游戏，
with everyone just trying to beat each other's prices. So I'm gonna say, I'm up there, I sold for a thousand, okay, I give it to you for 950. $50 is gonna make a difference for you. Fine, I don't even want to try. How are sales? It's a little too long, it's a little too long. We work in a smaller profession than ever be for you.
每个人都试图压过对方的价格。所以我说，我卖一千，好吧，我九百五卖给你。50美元对你来说会有所不同。好吧，我甚至不想尝试。生意怎么样？有点太久了，有点太久了。我们从事的职业比以往任何时候都更……
This new generation of marriage age people makes diamond sellers nervous. A lot of us millennials are encircling debt and we're struggling to pay exorbitant rents. And we really don't have a couple thousand dollars burning a hole in our pocket that we want to spend on a diamond, especially given the bad associations they carry. Blood diamonds.
新一代适婚年龄的人让钻石卖家感到紧张。我们很多千禧一代都背负着债务，在支付高昂的房租方面苦苦挣扎。我们真的没有几千美元闲钱想花在钻石上，尤其是考虑到它们所带来的负面联想。血钻。
No, like really not. Just in a cartoon evil villain, boy. I grew up hearing a lot of the same stories that Courtney did about how the diamond industry is exploitative and horrible. So blood diamonds or conflict diamonds are diamonds that come out of war zones where war and groups have been fighting over the alluvial fields where the diamonds exist in order to raise cash for their effort, which is violent. Rochelle Berkstein is the author of Brilliant and Fire, a biography of diamonds.
不，真的不是。只是像卡通里的邪恶反派那样。我和考特尼一样，从小就听过很多关于钻石行业如何剥削和可怕的故事。所以，血钻或冲突钻石是指来自战区的钻石，那里的战争和组织为了筹集资金而争夺钻石存在的冲积平原，这非常暴力。罗谢尔·伯克斯坦是《璀璨与火焰：钻石传记》的作者。
And then when they were getting the diamonds, they were sending them into the marketplace and diamond companies like DeBieres and other traders weren't really asking questions about where they came from. And they could easily have been funding devastation and violence and horrible things and no one was really thinking that much about it. That was until the late 90s,
当他们得到钻石时，他们把它们送进市场，而戴比尔斯和其他贸易商等钻石公司并没有真正询问它们的来源。它们很可能资助了破坏、暴力和可怕的事情，而没有人真正去想那么多。直到90年代末，
when a torrent of news and long form reporting came out about conflict diamonds and how they were used to fund insurgencies and warlords and all this attention eventually led to stricter protocols and tighter regulations within the diamond industry. Almost 90% of diamond supplies produced by very large corporations and they're very heavily regulated and they're very transparent. That's Diamond Industry, analyst Paul Zemniski, and he says now these big Diamond companies are not funding human rights abuses, although there are still conflict diamonds out there.
当大量关于冲突钻石的新闻和深度报道出现，揭露它们如何被用于资助叛乱和军阀时，所有这些关注最终促使钻石行业内部制定了更严格的协议和更紧密的监管。几乎90%的钻石供应由大型企业生产，它们受到严格监管，非常透明。这是钻石行业分析师保罗·泽姆尼斯基，他说现在这些大钻石公司并没有资助侵犯人权的行为，尽管市面上仍然存在冲突钻石。
I think it represents a very, very, very small part of supply, but it can create a PR problem for the industry. Listen, I'm not trying to give the diamond industry a pass here. The ethics of diamond mining are complicated. Like, diamond mines might not be funding armies of child soldiers anymore, but in a lot of cases, the working conditions are not ideal, especially in countries without a lot of labor oversight, like the Democratic Republic of the Congo. I mean, mining is still a hard job. And just creating a mine at all, digging an
我认为它只占供应中非常、非常、非常小的一部分，但它会给行业带来公关问题。听着，我不是想为钻石行业开脱。钻石开采的道德问题很复杂。比如，钻石矿可能不再资助童子军军队了，但在很多情况下，工作条件并不理想，特别是在缺乏劳工监管的国家，比如刚果民主共和国。我的意思是，采矿仍然是一项艰苦的工作。而且仅仅是建立一个矿场，在地球上挖掘一个
unfathomably huge crater in the earth, that is environmentally devastating, no matter how you slice it. But truly, diamonds aren't that different from other extractive industries. A lot of materials around us have been mined and manufactured in questionable ways, and we don't talk about them. Take, for example, cobalt. We use cobalt and testless, and we use it in our iPhones, and I mean almost all of that's produced in the Congo, and it's the exact same issue that the diamond industry has with diamonds producing the Congo. Diamonds are held to a different standard. I think people think that a Tesla is providing enough good or even for providing some bad by
深不可测的巨大陨石坑，无论你怎么看，这在环境上都是毁灭性的。但说实话，钻石与其他采掘业并没有什么不同。我们周围的许多材料都是以可疑的方式开采和制造的，而我们却不谈论它们。以钴为例。我们在特斯拉中使用钴，我们在iPhone中使用它，我的意思是几乎所有这些都产自刚果，这与钻石行业在刚果生产钻石的问题完全一样。钻石受到不同的标准对待。我认为人们认为特斯拉提供了足够的好处，或者即使提供了一些坏处，通过
trading demand for co-blot that comes there with the Congo. We'll kind of let that one go but since we don't need diamonds there's zero room for any illicit goods. We don't need diamonds. Even though it doesn't exactly feel that way, diamonds are almost culturally mandatory. They've become almost a requirement, if you want to get married, which leads to the other big thing
交易来自刚果的钴的需求。我们姑且放过那个，但既然我们不需要钻石，那么任何非法商品都没有立足之地。我们不需要钻石。尽管感觉并不完全是这样，但钻石在文化上几乎是强制性的。如果你想结婚，它们几乎成了必需品，这导致了另一件大事，
that made Courtney skeptical about diamonds. Maybe you've heard this too. That diamonds are a scam. The sort of bonkers inflation of the worth of a diamond, which is not actually that rare or valuable, but it was just like a gigantic marketing plate. Concerns about diamonds are concerns about value. These serons about diamonds are concerns about value. In both senses of the word, values as an ethics and morality and also value in terms of price. So let's talk about what these rocks are actually worth. A diamond industry and one of the things that I found so fascinating about it in my research
让考特尼对钻石持怀疑态度。也许你也听说过。钻石是一个骗局。这种对钻石价值的疯狂通胀，它实际上并不那么稀有或有价值，但这只是一个巨大的营销把戏。对钻石的担忧是对价值的担忧。这些关于钻石的讨论是对价值的担忧。在词语的两种含义上，价值作为伦理和道德，以及价格方面的价值。所以让我们谈谈这些石头到底值多少钱。钻石行业，我在研究中发现它最迷人的一点是
off the Rochelle Bergstein again. They're forever walking this tightrope, right? How do you convince people that diamonds are accessible enough that every woman should have one? But also keep them in the public imagination so rare and glamorous and special that you don't ruin it. Right. And that's what they've been working on forever. Diamonds were rare. Once, they were exceedingly rare. In the ancient world, diamonds were something only royalty could afford. And then suddenly, in the late 19th century, there was a huge supply of them. Diamonds became an industry when a whole bunch of them were discovered in South Africa, on a property owned by brothers Diedrich and Johannes De Beer.
再次提到罗谢尔·伯克斯坦。他们永远在走钢丝，对吧？你如何说服人们钻石足够普及，以至于每个女人都应该拥有一颗？但同时又让它们在公众想象中保持稀有、迷人且特别，以至于你不会毁了它。没错。这就是他们一直在努力做的事情。钻石曾经很稀有。曾经，它们极其稀有。在古代世界，钻石是只有皇室才买得起的东西。然后突然间，在19世纪末，出现了大量的供应。当一大批钻石在南非被发现时，钻石成为了一种产业，那是在迪德里希和约翰内斯·德比尔兄弟拥有的土地上。
They were farmers. Okay, so De Beer's actually had nothing to do with the De Beer's company. A massive diamond deposit was discovered on the De Beer's property, which you'd think would be a blessing, but it was too much of a good thing. The land became overrun with international mining interests, and eventually the British government would force the debirs to sell their property. The debir's mine turned out to be
他们是农民。好吧，所以德比尔实际上与德比尔公司毫无关系。在德比尔的土地上发现了一个巨大的钻石矿床，你可能会认为这是一种福气，但这是过犹不及。这片土地被国际采矿利益集团占领，最终英国政府强迫德比尔出售他们的财产。德比尔矿场后来成为了
one of the most productive mines in the area. The debir's brothers could have never known that their name would get adopted by the foremost diamond company in the world, which was run by a man named Cecil Rhodes. He was a sickly Englishman who followed his brother down to South Africa and down to the diamond rush. And there are funny pictures of him where he was like a dandy.
该地区产量最高的矿场之一。德比尔兄弟永远不会想到他们的名字会被世界上最重要的钻石公司采用，该公司由一个名叫塞西尔·罗兹的人经营。他是一个体弱多病的英国人，跟随他的兄弟来到南非，投身于钻石热潮。有一些关于他的有趣照片，他看起来像个花花公子。
Very much in the bowbrum away. He's among all of these people digging and covered in dust and carrying buckets, and he's like sitting there on an overturned bucket in a white suit looking, you know, glowering. Maybe it looked like he was glowering, but Cecil was scheming on behalf of his motherland. He felt this really strong internal drive to elevate the status of the United Kingdom. He felt like the Queen's special envoy, even though she had not given him this job. Sessel Roads is like the archetypal colonizer capitalist.
非常像博·布鲁梅尔风格。他在所有挖掘的人群中，浑身沾满灰尘，提着桶，而他坐在一个翻倒的桶上，穿着白西装，看起来，你知道，怒目而视。也许看起来他是在怒目而视，但塞西尔是在为他的祖国谋划。他内心有一种非常强烈的动力，想要提升联合王国的地位。他觉得自己是女王的特使，尽管她并没有给他这份工作。塞西尔·罗兹是典型的殖民者资本家。
You think of an old time of European guy in a pith helmet dressed from head to toe in khaki, with a mustache and a rifle at his hip, and that's Cecil Rhodes. He started by buying up all the little minds in South Africa and consolidating them. He grabbed up lands in Africa, left and right, and colonized.
你想到一个老派的欧洲人，戴着木髓头盔，从头到脚穿着卡其布，留着胡子，腰间别着步枪，那就是塞西尔·罗兹。他从收购南非所有的小矿场并整合它们开始。他在非洲左右开弓，抢占土地，进行殖民。
Like in modern Zimbabwe, formerly named Rhodesia after Cecil Rhodes. He created the Rhodes Scholarship to instruct and elevate young men who might follow out his mission as well. Yeah, they should consider changing that name. Cecil Rhodes created a dynasty that grew and grew and grew, eventually buying up all the diamonds coming out of Russia and Australia until the Dabier's company had amassed more diamonds than had ever been thought possible. But come on, Rhodes didn't want the public to know that.
就像在现代津巴布韦，以前以塞西尔·罗兹的名字命名为罗得西亚。他设立了罗兹奖学金，以指导和提升那些可能追随他使命的年轻人。是的，他们应该考虑改掉那个名字。塞西尔·罗兹建立了一个不断壮大的王朝，最终收购了所有来自俄罗斯和澳大利亚的钻石，直到德比尔公司积累的钻石数量达到了前所未有的程度。但拜托，罗兹不想让公众知道这一点。
He realized that in order to preserve the specialness of the diamond, you had to somehow control the output. You had to find a way to make them feel rare, even if they kind of weren't anymore. So did that mean literally stop piling them somewhere? It did. When jewelers like Tiffany's and Harry Winston and Cartier, wanted to buy diamonds, they had to come to Debeer's stockpile in London. Roads intentionally limited the supply to jack up the price.
他意识到，为了保持钻石的特殊性，你必须以某种方式控制产量。你必须找到一种方法让它们感觉稀有，即使它们已经不再那么稀有了。所以这意味着真的把它们囤积在某个地方吗？是的。当蒂芙尼、哈利·温斯顿和卡地亚这样的珠宝商想要购买钻石时，他们必须来到德比尔在伦敦的库存地。罗兹故意限制供应以抬高价格。
But even as he limited the supply at the same time, his company was pushing public demand. They were both a mining company and a marketing company. Debeer's wasn't allowed to advertise in the US because they were a monopoly in America and forced anti-trust laws back then. So as a workaround, Debeers decided to market the general idea of diamonds. After all, they mined most of the diamonds in the world anyway.
但即使他在限制供应的同时，他的公司也在推动公众需求。他们既是一家矿业公司，也是一家营销公司。德比尔不被允许在美国做广告，因为他们当时在美国是垄断企业，受到反垄断法的限制。所以作为一种变通方法，德比尔决定推销钻石的一般概念。毕竟，他们无论如何都开采了世界上大部分的钻石。
If Debeers could get people to buy diamonds from whatever jeweler, they'd still be making money. And so, debiers created the tradition of the diamond engagement ring. Because if you can't sell diamonds for millions of dollars to royalty, you can sell diamonds for thousands of dollars to everyone. Debeers created this idea that every single couple must buy a diamond. Don't get me wrong, wedding rings have been around a very long time, but diamond engagement rings are decidedly 20th century. Is this the very first diamond ad? This is the first.
如果德比尔能让人从任何珠宝商那里购买钻石，他们仍然能赚钱。于是，德比尔创造了钻石订婚戒指的传统。因为如果你不能把钻石以数百万美元的价格卖给皇室，你可以把钻石以数千美元的价格卖给每个人。德比尔创造了这个想法，即每一对情侣都必须购买一颗钻石。别误会，结婚戒指已经存在很长时间了，但钻石订婚戒指绝对是20世纪的产物。这是第一则钻石广告吗？这是第一则。
Oh my god, it's sober boost. Looks like a page from a book. Okay, this is so funny. These early Diamond ads are not what I would call compelling. The beautiful flame of a diamond is unquenchable. However modest, your wife will never relinquish it to meet more affluent circumstances. That's one of my favorite lines. But then in 1948, Debiere's launched what is arguably the most successful advertising campaign of the 20th century.
天哪，这太枯燥了。看起来像书里的一页。好吧，这太搞笑了。这些早期的钻石广告并不是我所说的引人注目。钻石美丽的火焰是无法熄灭的。无论多么谦逊，你的妻子永远不会为了满足更富裕的环境而放弃它。这是我最喜欢的台词之一。但后来在1948年，德比尔发起了可以说是20世纪最成功的广告活动。
Really incredible young copyrighter named Frances Garrity, she worked for NW Air and son the advertising company. And Frances Garrity was given the task of coming up with a tagline for the ads. Legend has it, Frances was really coming down to the wire the night before the tagline was due. She stayed up all night and she couldn't think of anything. And then at 5am, she scribbled out. Uh, Diamond is forever. She came into the office and said, here's what I've got. And the senior copywriter gave her a side eye and said, well, I don't even think that's grammatically correct.
一位非常有才华的年轻文案撰稿人名叫弗朗西丝·格雷蒂，她在NW Ayer & Son广告公司工作。弗朗西丝·格雷蒂被委派为广告想出一句标语。传说，在标语截止日期的前一天晚上，弗朗西丝真的到了最后关头。她熬了一整夜，什么也想不出来。然后在凌晨5点，她潦草地写下：钻石恒久远。她走进办公室说，这是我想到的。资深文案给了她一个白眼说，好吧，我觉得这在语法上都不正确。
But they run out of time, so they just rolled with it. But nobody, nobody for saw what this tagline would become. A diamond is forever. A diamond is forever forever forever forever. Visit a diamondisforever.com. And in this way, through engagement rings, debirs convince the world that diamonds are the rarest, truest, most valuable of the stones.
但他们时间不够了，所以就用了它。但没有人，没有人预见到这句标语会变成什么样。钻石恒久远。钻石恒久远，恒久远，恒久远，恒久远。访问 adiamondisforever.com。就这样，通过订婚戒指，德比尔让全世界相信钻石是所有宝石中最稀有、最真实、最有价值的。
So aside from just generally convincing the customer that he should buy a diamond or that she should demand a diamond, these ads also had the intention of saying, these are the different cuts. This is how much they cost, things like that. In their ads and in pamphlets made for diamond sellers, debirs informed the consumer about exactly how much money they should spend.
所以除了普遍说服顾客他应该买一颗钻石，或者她应该要求一颗钻石之外，这些广告还有意传达：这是不同的切工。这是它们的价格，诸如此类。在他们的广告和为钻石卖家制作的小册子中，德比尔告知消费者他们到底应该花多少钱。
And to a degree, this is still true for diamond engagement rings today. The person selling you the diamond is probably the one educating you about them. I mean, it's hyper just price. There's a lot of education involved, and it can be emotionally wavy. So we really want people when they're coming into the showroom to feel relaxed, like they're having fun. Brilliant Earth is a diamond retailer with six showrooms around the US. I'm Catherine Money, Vice President of merchandising and strategy at Brilliant Earth.
在某种程度上，这对今天的钻石订婚戒指仍然适用。卖给你钻石的人可能就是那个教育你的人。我的意思是，这纯粹是价格。涉及很多教育，而且可能会让人情绪波动。所以我们真的希望人们在走进陈列室时感到放松，就像他们在享受乐趣一样。Brilliant Earth是一家在美国拥有六家陈列室的钻石零售商。我是凯瑟琳·莫尼，Brilliant Earth的营销和战略副总裁。
So you are not the person who will come to greet a couple? Typically no. Typically we have a jewelry specialist who's working with a couple and they're having this one-on-one interaction, very focused on education, sitting down learning about the four C's. The four C's is a shorthand created by debiers
所以你不是那个会来迎接情侣的人？通常不是。通常我们有一位珠宝专家与情侣合作，他们进行这种一对一的互动，非常专注于教育，坐下来学习“4C”标准。4C是德比尔创造的速记法，
to assess the rarity and therefore value of a diamond. It's still in use today. The four C's are cut. Cut measures symmetry, polish, and proportion, color. It's rated on a color scale from D, which is the most rare, and we will sell D through J. Carrot, it's a measure of weight and clarity. Clarity is determined under 10 times magnification
用来评估钻石的稀有度，从而评估其价值。它至今仍在使用。4C是切工（Cut）。切工衡量对称性、抛光和比例；颜色（Color）。它在颜色等级上进行评级，从D级开始，这是最稀有的，我们销售D到J级。克拉（Carat），这是重量的衡量标准；净度（Clarity）。净度是在10倍放大镜下由
by a trained gemologist since most of the characteristics can't be seen by the naked eye. So that's the thing. If you can't see it with the naked eye, like if it's not for aesthetics, then what is this for? Is a rare diamond.
训练有素的宝石学家确定的，因为大多数特征肉眼是看不见的。所以就是这样。如果你肉眼看不见，如果它不是为了美观，那这是为了什么？是一颗稀有的钻石。
One that's got good color or cut or clarity or carrot, actually worth anything. Is it an asset? Is it like investing in a house or buying a piece of art? In fact, a diamond is much more like a car where once you've taken out of the lot, where once you've taken out of the lot, the value permits. Reshellbergstein's answer is, most typical engagement diamonds aren't worth much. Unless the diamond is exceedingly special, like it is ridiculously preposterously big, or was cut by Harry Winston himself, or worn by Elizabeth Taylor. Those are worth a lot. But for the most part, the value of a diamond ring comes from who wore it, or touched it, or cut it.
一颗具有良好颜色、切工、净度或克拉的钻石，真的值钱吗？它是一项资产吗？它就像投资房子或购买艺术品一样吗？事实上，钻石更像是一辆汽车，一旦你把它开出车行，价值就会下降。罗谢尔·伯克斯坦的回答是，大多数典型的订婚钻石并不值多少钱。除非这颗钻石极其特别，比如它大得离谱，或者是由哈利·温斯顿本人切割的，或者由伊丽莎白·泰勒佩戴过。那些才值钱。但在大多数情况下，钻石戒指的价值来自于谁戴过它、碰过它或切割过它。
So unless you're a celebrity... You can't flip a diamonds. No one's gonna buy it back from you for the same price that you paid for it. Why? First of all, because you paid retail, and whoever you're selling it back to is not gonna pay that same retail mark and whoever you're selling it back to is not going to pay that same retail markup, you're going to take a loss. And second of all, if it's just your run of the mill diamond engagement ring with like
所以除非你是名人……你无法转手钻石。没有人会以你支付的相同价格把它买回去。为什么？首先，因为你支付的是零售价，而任何你卖回给它的人都不会支付同样的零售加价，你会亏本。其次，如果它只是你普通的钻石订婚戒指，带有
a decent quality stone, there are diamond dozen. And there are dozens more beautiful, brilliant diamonds being grown every single day This is the other thing that feels freshly ridiculous about the myth of diamonds Like how can we possibly think they are rare if you can grow them in a laboratory Real diamonds not knockoffs like cubic zirconia Stones that are chemically identical. There are literally Diamonds growing in that room with a sincecessant hallucination inducing hum that never stops. Are you okay?
一颗质量尚可的石头，那简直多如牛毛。而且每天都有几十颗更美丽、更璀璨的钻石被培育出来。这是另一件关于钻石神话感觉新鲜可笑的事情。如果你能在实验室里培育它们，我们怎么可能认为它们稀有呢？真正的钻石，不是像立方氧化锆那样的仿制品。化学成分完全相同的石头。那个房间里真的有钻石在生长，伴随着一种永不停歇的、令人产生幻觉的嗡嗡声。你还好吗？
Fine. What's wrong? He's getting over it. Jonathan Levine Miles is the CEO of J2 materials. John Seraldo is the CTO of J2 materials, and the fact that they're named John and John a thing is why they're called J2. They grow and sell diamonds used for engagement rings, but that's not why they got into the diamond business. They aren't particularly interested in rings.
很好。怎么了？他正在克服它。乔纳森·莱文·迈尔斯是J2 Materials的首席执行官。约翰·塞拉尔多是J2 Materials的首席技术官，他们名字都叫约翰和约翰，这就是他们被称为J2的原因。他们培育并销售用于订婚戒指的钻石，但这并不是他们进入钻石行业的原因。他们对戒指并不特别感兴趣。
They're interested in the way diamonds can be used in future technology. Every time we sell a gemstone, it will inevitably help fund our diamond semiconductor research. As computers get more and more advanced, Silicon might not be able to handle all their processing power. So diamond might become a good alternative material for computer chips. But this would require large plates of diamond that are perfectly clear and smooth. And John and Jonathan can't sit around and wait for the Earth's crust to produce that.
他们对钻石在未来技术中的应用方式感兴趣。我们每卖出一颗宝石，都不可避免地会帮助资助我们的钻石半导体研究。随着计算机变得越来越先进，硅可能无法处理它们所有的处理能力。所以钻石可能会成为计算机芯片的一种很好的替代材料。但这需要完美透明且光滑的大块钻石。而约翰和乔纳森不能坐等地球的地壳产生那种东西。
Which means it has to be grown in the lab. And so fundamentally that's what we are trying to do here. J2 materials is in a strip mall in the suburbs of Chicago. It's a kind of space that could just as easily be a dentist's office. But it's filled with reactors. The moment we turned on our first reactor as it, when it was just the two of us, it was on 24-7. It shuts down just long enough to take out the diamonds, to clean the chamber, and to start it up again. So we never shut down.
这意味着它必须在实验室中培育。所以从根本上说，这就是我们在这里试图做的事情。J2 Materials位于芝加哥郊区的一个购物中心。这种空间很容易被误认为是牙医诊所。但它充满了反应堆。当我们开启第一个反应堆时，当时只有我们两个人，它24小时全天候运转。它只在取出钻石、清洁腔室并重新启动时才会关闭。所以我们从不关机。
These reactors look like rice cookers blown up to the size of washing machines. And normally, we think of diamonds being created in the earth under a lot of pressure, but that's not what's happening here. An extremely simplified way to explain J2's approach is that they're taking small bits of carbon and growing them into full diamonds. Almost in the same way you would grow a crop, where some turn out beautifully and some are duds, like how some potatoes turn out hardy and strong, and others end up small or lopsided or heart-shaped.
这些反应堆看起来像被放大到洗衣机大小的电饭煲。通常，我们认为钻石是在地球深处的高压下形成的，但这里发生的情况并非如此。解释J2方法的一种极其简化的方式是，他们取少量碳并将其培育成完整的钻石。几乎就像你种植农作物一样，有的长得很漂亮，有的则是次品，就像有的土豆长得结实强壮，而另一些则长得又小又歪或呈心形。
It's not a mass-produced thing, it isn't art. It is a complicated thing. I'll probably put it a little more bluntly and say, I think there's, as a scientist, of course, big caveat. There's tremendous beauty in being able to take essentially cowfarts and converting it into this technologically advanced yet beautiful material. Diamonds have been synthesized in laboratories since 1950, but it used to be mostly for industrial uses, like for surgical knives or the knives used to cut aluminum for iPhones. It's only very recently, like in the last couple of years,
这不是大规模生产的东西，它不是艺术。这是一件复杂的事情。我可能会说得更直白一点，作为一名科学家，当然有一个很大的警告。能够将本质上是牛屁的东西转化为这种技术先进而又美丽的材料，有着巨大的美感。钻石自1950年以来就在实验室中合成，但过去主要用于工业用途，比如手术刀或用于切割iPhone铝材的刀具。直到最近，也就是过去几年，
that laboratory-grown diamonds have started to look just as beautiful as the ones from the ground. Again, John and Jonathan didn't set out to make engagement rings, but businesses like theirs have put the traditional diamond industry on edge. We've definitely seen significant growth in lab diamonds. So consumer acceptance, particularly among millennial consumers, has increased.
实验室培育的钻石才开始看起来和地里挖出来的一样漂亮。同样，约翰和乔纳森并不是为了制作订婚戒指而开始的，但像他们这样的企业让传统钻石行业感到不安。我们确实看到了实验室钻石的显著增长。所以消费者的接受度，特别是在千禧一代消费者中，已经提高。
We do. We do. Yeah. Catherine, money of brilliant earth told me that lab-grown diamonds are sold almost interchangeably with mind diamonds. They are also assessed for rarity using the four C's. The main difference is that they're cheaper. And generally, consumers are drawn to lab-created diamonds because they're beautiful, they're responsible,
我们确实看到了。是的。Brilliant Earth的凯瑟琳·莫尼告诉我，实验室培育的钻石与开采的钻石几乎可以互换销售。它们也使用4C标准来评估稀有度。主要区别在于它们更便宜。通常，消费者被实验室培育的钻石所吸引，因为它们美丽、负责任，
and they're affordable. Lab diamonds do use a lot of energy to keep the reactors humming, but it's certainly less energy intensive than digging a massive crater in the earth. Lab diamonds seem like an ethical, attainable option, especially to a generation of marriage-age consumers who are broke and
而且负担得起。实验室钻石确实需要消耗大量能源来保持反应堆运转，但这肯定比在地球上挖掘一个巨大的陨石坑更节能。实验室钻石似乎是一个合乎道德、可实现的选择，特别是对于一代适婚年龄的消费者来说，他们没钱，
were raised in the 90s and 2000s among whispers of blood diamonds. The diamond industry is still reeling from that blood diamond reckoning over 20 years ago. Back then, debiers was rightfully worried that people would boycott them and that the value of diamonds would plummet. So, debiers did something pretty drastic. They sold off a lot of their diamond reserve. They ended their own monopoly. Between, I would say, 2000 and 2004, debiers liquidated their stock fly-on. You saw other companies emerge in the space, other diamond producers. Debeers relinquished control of the global diamond supply.
并且是在90年代和2000年代关于血钻的窃窃私语中长大的。钻石行业仍在从20多年前那场血钻清算中恢复。当时，德比尔理所当然地担心人们会抵制他们，钻石的价值会暴跌。所以，德比尔做了一些相当激进的事情。他们卖掉了大量的钻石储备。他们结束了自己的垄断。我想在2000年到2004年之间，德比尔清算了他们的库存。你看到了其他公司在这个领域出现，其他钻石生产商。德比尔放弃了对全球钻石供应的控制。
Consequently, they stopped advertising for all diamonds. The beers went from being the only player in the industry to one of several. And as a result, the mind diamond industry has slowed down a lot. Almost nobody's exploring for diamonds. Nobody's voting new diamond mines. So I think we actually could run to situation where there's like a shortage of diamonds in the future.
因此，他们停止了所有钻石的广告。德比尔从行业中唯一的参与者变成了众多参与者之一。结果，开采钻石行业放缓了很多。几乎没有人去勘探钻石。没有人去开采新的钻石矿。所以我认为我们实际上可能会在未来面临钻石短缺的情况。
Paul argues that in like five to 10 years, diamonds from the earth will become rare again. Because fewer mines are being cultivated, that scarcity that debiers faked through their monopoly might actually come true. So this means there's two kinds of diamonds in the market right now. Mind or natural diamonds, the kind that are getting rarer and more expensive, and lab-grown diamonds or man-made diamonds, which are proliferating and getting cheaper. The question is, can you tell the difference and does it matter?
保罗认为，在5到10年内，来自地球的钻石将再次变得稀有。因为开采的矿山越来越少，德比尔通过垄断伪造的那种稀缺性可能真的会实现。所以这意味着市场上现在有两种钻石。开采的或天然的钻石，那种变得越来越稀有和昂贵的钻石；以及实验室培育的或人造的钻石，它们正在激增并变得越来越便宜。问题是，你能分辨出区别吗？这重要吗？
So I think it's important to make the distinction that man-made and natural diamonds can be distinguished with certainty. Yeah, I mean, that's interesting that you're talking all this work and you didn't even realize that. Listen Paul, I can't see the difference between lab diamonds and natural diamonds. You can't with the naked eye.
所以我认为做出区分很重要，人造钻石和天然钻石是可以确定地分辨出来的。是的，我的意思是，你做了这么多工作，甚至没有意识到这一点，这很有趣。听着保罗，我看不出实验室钻石和天然钻石的区别。你肉眼看不出来。
And even with the official fancy equipment, some diamond sellers in the diamond district can't tell the difference either. When you're regular test, diamond test you say diamond book. When I visited the diamond district, I asked a couple jewelers to look at a pair of lab-grown diamond earrings. I know for a fact that these earrings are lab-grown. They were sent to me by a lab-grown diamond company. And these two diamond sellers, with booths across from each other, took turns testing each earring. And I am fairly certain that they both got it wrong.
即使有官方的精良设备，钻石区的一些钻石卖家也分辨不出来。当你进行常规测试，钻石测试时，你说钻石书。当我访问钻石区时，我请几位珠宝商看一对实验室培育的钻石耳环。我确切地知道这些耳环是实验室培育的。它们是由一家实验室培育钻石公司寄给我的。而这两位钻石卖家，摊位就在彼此对面，轮流测试每一只耳环。我相当肯定他们两个都弄错了。
What is he up to doing? One wanted. Yeah, I was going to go all the way up to the machine. That was actually a jackpot. He said that one's a jackpot. Because both jewelers told me that one earring was, quote, unquote, real. And the other was lab-grown. One diamond seller offered to buy the real diamond
他在做什么？一个想要。是的，我打算一直走到机器那里。那实际上是一个大奖。他说那个是大奖。因为两位珠宝商都告诉我，一只耳环是“所谓的”真品。而另一只是实验室培育的。一位钻石卖家提出购买那颗真钻石，
for between $500 to $1000. $500 to $1000 is not... Nothing assays that. It's not chicken feet, right? And then the other one you'd sell in a very low price. Like what's a really low price for that one? Like $100, really? You can't tag both, but it's fake.
价格在500到1000美元之间。500到1000美元不是……没什么能评估那个。这不是鸡脚，对吧？然后另一个你以非常低的价格卖掉。那个低价是多少？比如100美元，真的吗？你不能给两个都贴标签，但它是假的。
You know, it's not fake, but it's lab-grown. I don't know if you could hear that, but he said the lab-grown diamond would only be worth about $100. So one earring was supposedly worth 10 times more than the other. And again, I can't emphasize enough that this pair of earrings came from the same laboratory. We value diamonds for their perceived worth so much more than anything about the way they actually look.
你知道，它不是假的，但它是实验室培育的。我不知道你是否听到了，但他说了实验室培育的钻石只值100美元左右。所以一只耳环据称比另一只值钱10倍。再说一次，我怎么强调都不为过，这对耳环来自同一个实验室。我们评估钻石的价值，更多是基于它们感知的价值，而不是它们实际看起来的样子。
I sell an age rate for $2,000. Did I go to Kedger rate for $2,000. Did I go to the kid's right or $8,000 or a price? Oh, I can't do that. I'm not doing that. You know, because they want to put that in front of the girl. You know, say I bought it at $8,000. I mean, it's kind of smart.
我以2000美元卖出一个等级。我以2000美元卖给孩子。我以8000美元卖给孩子，还是一个价格？哦，我做不到。我不做那个。你知道，因为他们想把它放在女孩面前。你知道，说我花了8000美元买的。我的意思是，这挺聪明的。
Oh, I always say if you're going to start a relationship that way. I'm not going very long. You know, I've got to buy a pair. Never mind. Not a good idea. Don't lie to your partner. But I guess it still just seems odd to talk about how much your proposal diamond costs if you can't see the difference.
哦，我总是说如果你打算以那种方式开始一段关系。我不会持续太久。你知道，我得买一对。没关系。不是个好主意。不要对你的伴侣撒谎。但我猜，如果你看不出区别，谈论你的求婚钻石花了多少钱似乎还是很奇怪。
I mean, it shouldn't matter, right? And the question is, would proposing to someone with a $100 diamond would have kind of the same impact? And this is, you know, something that's not practical or not rational. So I don't see a diamond as an investment and the material object, but it's probably an investment and a commitment that you're trying to portray. Catherine Money at Brilliant Earth
我的意思是，这不应该重要，对吧？问题是，用一颗100美元的钻石向某人求婚会有同样的影响吗？这是，你知道，一些不切实际或不理性的事情。所以我并不把钻石看作是一种投资和物质对象，但它可能是一种投资，以及你试图描绘的承诺。Brilliant Earth的凯瑟琳·莫尼
gave me pretty much the same answer that diamonds are valuable because they are tied to our deepest relationships. It's a representation of commitment and love and values. At the time I thought this answer was a bit of an evasive cop-out, but it's not! This is how real, tangible value has been created and assigned. By debirs, sure, and by all of us. By everyone, myself included, who wondered if Courtney and Sean were really
给了我几乎同样的回答，即钻石之所以有价值，是因为它们与我们最深层的关系联系在一起。它是承诺、爱和价值观的代表。当时我觉得这个回答有点逃避，但事实并非如此！这就是真实的、有形的价值是如何被创造和分配的。当然是德比尔，也是我们所有人。每个人，包括我自己，都怀疑考特尼和肖恩是否真的
engaged without a ring. Without a diamond. I thought that I was better than that. But you're not. But I'm not! Look at this friggin' sparkly thing. Let me see it. It's so beautiful.
在没有戒指的情况下订婚了。没有钻石。我以为我比那更好。但你不是。但我不是！看看这个该死的闪闪发光的东西。让我看看。它太美了。
Courtney caved. I was like, okay, we can get rings. I give in. But we have to get them vintage. If you really wanted to get a diamond and minimize your impact, a vintage diamond is the way to go. Compared to digging a massive hole in the earth or a room full of humming reactors,
考特尼屈服了。我说，好吧，我们可以买戒指。我认输。但我们必须买复古的。如果你真的想买一颗钻石并尽量减少你的影响，复古钻石是最好的选择。与在地球上挖一个巨大的洞或一个充满嗡嗡声反应堆的房间相比，
your grandmother's ring doesn't emit any fresh carbon. We went to the Alameda Fleet Market. Courtney's ring has not one, but two diamonds. And in the center is a ruby. Sean's ring has a sapphire. It ended up being ruby and sapphire. I ended up with ruby, which is the Pokemon game I'm playing. And Sean ended up with sapphire, which is the Pokemon game she's playing.
你祖母的戒指不会排放任何新鲜碳。我们去了阿拉米达跳蚤市场。考特尼的戒指不仅有一颗，而且有两颗钻石。中间是一颗红宝石。肖恩的戒指有一颗蓝宝石。最终变成了红宝石和蓝宝石。我最终得到了红宝石，这是我正在玩的宝可梦游戏。而肖恩最终得到了蓝宝石，这是她正在玩的宝可梦游戏。
It's so cute. Their rings still fit into their nerdy little world. And even though Diamond Engagement rings are built on a bedrock of BS-concocted tradition, all traditions get made up somehow. And they become more authentic as they get ossified in time. Courtney and Sean love their rings rings because they love each other. It is not and has never been a rational thing. The pocket, the piece of paper Words from yesterday There's a portrait painted on the things we love.
这太可爱了。他们的戒指仍然适合他们书呆子般的小世界。尽管钻石订婚戒指建立在胡编乱造的传统基础上，但所有传统都是以某种方式编造出来的。随着时间的推移，它们变得更加真实。考特尼和肖恩喜欢他们的戒指，因为他们相爱。这从来都不是，也永远不会是一件理性的事情。口袋，那张纸，昨天的词语，在我们所爱之物上画着一幅肖像。
Articles of Interest was written and performed by Avery Truffelman, edited by Chris Baroube with additional edits from Emmett Fitzgerald and Joe Rosenberg, scored by Ray Royal, fact-checked by Tom Colligan with additional fact-checking by Graham Haysha, Mixing Tech Production by Sharif Yusef with additional mixing by Catherine Ray Mondo. Our opening and closing songs are by Sassami. Special thanks to Alex Weinling, Jay Metta and John Fassil. Insight support and edits from a whole 99PI team, including Vivian Le, Sean Rial, Abby Madon, Kurt Colstead, Delaney Hall and Katie Mingle. And Roman Mars is the rare gem of this whole series. There's a portrait of painting the things we love.
《Articles of Interest》由艾弗里·特鲁费尔曼撰写并表演，克里斯·巴鲁贝编辑，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德和乔·罗森伯格额外编辑，雷·罗亚尔配乐，汤姆·科利根核实事实，格雷厄姆·海沙额外核实事实，沙里夫·尤塞夫混音技术制作，凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多额外混音。我们的开场和结尾歌曲由Sassami演唱。特别感谢亚历克斯·温林、杰伊·梅塔和约翰·法西尔。感谢整个99PI团队的洞察支持和编辑，包括薇薇安·勒、肖恩·里亚尔、艾比·马登、库尔特·科尔斯特德、德莱尼·霍尔和凯蒂·明格尔。罗曼·马尔斯是整个系列的稀有宝石。在我们所爱之物上画着一幅肖像。
With the invention of the engagement ring came the invention of the engagement period. A time where you have a ring on your finger but you're not yet a spouse. It was an invention of a new stage of life. The bride, the category of bride, and when I use that word, I'm really using it in the way that the wedding industry uses it, which is to say this young woman who's at this stage of her life and that maybe engaged and going through this process is an incredibly valuable proposition for all kinds of businesses. Author Rebecca Meade says, someone used to be a bride for a day, and now you're a bride for as long as it takes to plan your wedding, which has gotten more and more elaborate.
随着订婚戒指的发明，订婚期也随之产生。那是一段你手指上有戒指但还不是配偶的时间。这是对人生新阶段的发明。新娘，新娘这个类别，当我使用这个词时，我实际上是在婚礼行业使用它的方式来使用它，也就是说，这个处于人生阶段的年轻女性，可能已经订婚并正在经历这个过程，这对各种企业来说是一个非常有价值的命题。作家丽贝卡·米德说，以前一个人当一天新娘，而现在你当新娘的时间取决于筹备婚礼所需的时间，这已经变得越来越复杂了。
You know, I found an article that was published in 1939 called The Cost of Weddings in the American Sociological Review, and a third of the brides didn't have an engagement ring. Sixteen percent were married in clothes they already owned, a third of them married without a wedding reception in addition to the ceremony, and about a third of them didn't have a honeymoon. So these things that we think of as like absolutely core elements of what a wedding is, just one, necessarily core elements.
你知道，我发现了一篇1939年发表在《美国社会学评论》上的文章，题为《婚礼的成本》，三分之一的新娘没有订婚戒指。16%的人穿着她们已经拥有的衣服结婚，三分之一的人在仪式之外没有举行婚礼招待会，大约三分之一的人没有度蜜月。所以这些我们认为像婚礼核心要素的东西，只是，并不一定是核心要素。
The wedding industry has emerged to convince brides that you're not really a bride without a massive cake, without a rehearsal dinner, without a lingerie set, without something old and something new and something borrowed and something blue. And we all know that no one needs a party that might cost tens of thousands of dollars. We live in a consumer culture, we're not ignorant of the fact that we're being sold stuff that we don't need. And you know, we all have some discretion and some sense of distance on that. But when you're being told this is how it's done. You just want to do it all the right way.
婚庆产业的兴起就是为了让新娘们相信，如果没有巨大的蛋糕、彩排晚宴、成套的内衣，没有“旧的、新的、借来的、蓝色的”东西，你就不是真正的新娘。我们都知道，没有人需要一场可能花费数万美元的派对。我们生活在消费文化中，我们并非不知道自己正在被推销不需要的东西。你知道，我们对此都有一定的判断力和距离感。但当有人告诉你这就是婚礼该有的样子时，你只想以正确的方式完成这一切。
And if you don't do it like this, then you know, maybe you're not doing it properly, and if you're not doing your wedding properly, maybe you're not properly committed to your marriage. Your next articles of interest are wedding dresses. Thanks. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你不这样做，那么你知道，也许你做得就不够妥当；如果你没有妥善处理你的婚礼，也许你对婚姻的承诺也不够坚定。你接下来感兴趣的文章是关于婚纱的。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。